así
hasta ahora hemos hecho algunas
subdivisiones con solamente cuatro
puntos que hacen una mancha pero si
vamos a hacer algo tan genial como un
personaje de pixar vamos a necesitar
muchos más puntos por ejemplo qué tal si
quiero modelar el contorno de mi mano o
el perfil de un personaje
afortunadamente a la subdivisión no le
importa cuántos puntos empiezas en este
interactivo podemos mover puntos como
antes pero también podemos agregar todos
los puntos nuevos que queramos solo das
clic en el interior del borde para crear
un nuevo punto y después usando el ratón
arrastras el punto nuevo a donde quieras
puedo hacer que mi mano tenga una forma
tosca como esta usa el deslizador para
controlar qué tantas subdivisiones se
usan para obtener un resultado más suave
usando el interactivo hay una mano o lo
que quieras
tal vez un dinosaurio o el contorno de
mike wazowski o lo que quieras se
creativo